we put some of tangulls weirdest teams
under the microscope only to find out
that they actually make sense yes that's
right even Mother Gothel spontaneous
combustion has a credible explanation
watch until the end to find out what it
is love that first fight if there's one
thing Rapunzel has taught us it's that a
cast-iron frying pan is literally the
best weapon ever just ask Flynn Rider or
should we say Eugene Rapunzel knocked
Flint out hold on two separate occasions
which should have resulted in a severe
concussion or some brain damage at the
very least
however when Flynn awoke there were no
bumps or bruises in sight while most
Disney movies are filled with impossible
scenes many of us couldn't get over the
fact that Flynn should have been in a
coma after what Rapunzel did to him
however this scene is actually possible
after all when Flynn wakes up Rapunzel's
hair is wrapped around him so she
probably saying the healing song to get
him to wake up it's in that pop isn't it
the healing song hundreds of years
before the events of tangled took place
an old Mother Gothel accidentally
stumbled across the Sun drop flower but
how on earth could she have known to
sing the healing song to it
well according to Disney Press the
lyrics have little to do with the
flowers abilities in fact the flowers
powers bloom when someone begins to sing
it in general and Mother Gothel happened
to be singing when she first discovered
the flower which magically turned her
into her younger self over time Mother
Gothel created a special song for the
flower she convinced Rapunzel that her
hair could only heal with the help of
the healing song
however she might have been manipulating
her to prevent her from knowing just how
powerful she truly was suddenly this
once puzzling phenomena makes total
sense
the missing princess here's something we
never understood why would mother Gothel
kidnap a baby but keep the missing
child's name and birthday Minnie tangled
fans believe this to be a major plot
hole when in reality it makes a whole
lot of sense
first of all Mother Gothel is highly
intelligent and she probably knew that
naming a baby would make her feel
connected
and she didn't want to love Rapunzel she
just wanted to use her secondly Mother
Gothel never changed Rapunzel's birthday
because she didn't feel she needed to
how was she supposed to know that the
king and queen of corona would light
lanterns every year in honor of their
missing daughter
by the time Rapunzel began asking about
the birthday lanterns the damage was
done
Sun dropped flower if the origins of the
Sun drop flower have ever puzzled you
you're not alone it stated that a cosmic
event created a single drop of sunlight
which fell onto earth many centuries ago
the drop infused with soil creating a
luminous flower with healing properties
to grow this magical plant isn't
something that can be explained which is
why we talk it up to magic after some
digging we found out that in Greek
mythology there's a Sun God named Apollo
who's known for his music poetry art
medicine and knowledge so the Sun drop
flower was probably infused with
Apollo's essence this explains why the
flower has healing abilities and why
Rapunzel is so artsy fartsy the hidden
tower you would think that mother father
would have tried to get us far away from
Corona as possible after kidnapping the
King and queens newborn child because
well the closer she remained to Corona
the more chances she had of being caught
right well not necessarily as it turns
out Mother Gothel had a limited amount
of time to make her great escape after
realizing that their daughter had been
kidnapped
Rapunzel's parents sent their guards out
to retrieve her this means that every
single person with a newborn baby would
be a suspect
bottles best chance was to hide Rapunzel
as quickly as possible so she found a
Hidden Valley where she could raise
Rapunzel without being found
suddenly staying in Corona makes a lot
of sense the lanterns no one batted an
eye when Eugene spontaneously lit two
lanterns and Rapunzel's honor we don't
see Eugene striking a match and the
lanterns aren't lit at the beginning of
that I see the light song yet
somehow when Rapunzel looks back at
Eugene he's holding two lit lanterns in
his hands so were these lanterns
magically late we highly doubt it
Eugene and Rapunzel's boat has a lantern
attached to it so perhaps Eugene used
the existing flame to light the birthday
Lea and turn
rapunzel's back was turned another
explanation is that Eugene caught two
floating lanterns before they could fall
into the water or maybe Eugene had a
match or two up his sleeves don't talk
to strangers Rapunzel was born and
raised tippier strangers but for some
strange reason she began embracing them
throughout the film this literally makes
no sense but on second thought it kind
of does
Rapunzel never had any friends oh sorry
Pascal we take it back Rapunzel only
ever had one friend so when she realized
that people weren't as evil as she was
led to believe she embraced strangers at
every turn Rapunzel was naive desperate
for human contact so it makes sense that
she would forego her mother's orders to
go on a life-changing adventure
Rapunzel's almighty hair if there's one
thing tangled fans can't help that
question its how strong Rapunzel's hair
is we mean since when can people's hair
support their entire body weight and
more weed out that Rapunzel's using
Pantene pro-v on a daily basis so this
has to be a pothole right wrong as it
turns out hair is extremely strong like
incredibly so according to the Guardian
there are over 150,000 strands of hair
on the average human head and each
strand can hold 100 grams of weight
before snapping an entire mane of hair
could actually support the weight of two
elephants combined so what we once
thought to be make-believe actually
checks out there is nothing magical
about it
another one bites the dust if there's
one mystery that has plagued us from the
very beginning its Mother Gothel turning
to dust a few seconds after Eugene cut
off Rapunzel's hair Pepper's we believe
this to be a major plot hole we mean why
would Mother Gothel pass away if
Rapunzel's powers were still intact we
soon find out that Rapunzel can heal
people with her tears so what's up with
Goethals spontaneous combustion we dug
around to find the truth at the
beginning of the movie Gothel tries to
cut off a strand of Rapunzel's hair but
it turns brown in her hands the fact
that Gothel is touching the now brown
hair causes her hand to start aging
rapidly and at the time of Goethals
death she was also holding on to
Rapunzel's brown
if she hadn't grabbed onto Rapunzel's
brown locks in a moment of desperation
she would still be alive are there any
other plot holes entangled that you want
us to explain let us know in the comment
section below and that's a wrap
give this video a big thumbs up if you
think Rapunzel and Eugene are couple
goals and feature to subscribe to the
things for the latest Disney news thanks
for watching we'll see you soon
[Music]